the medicine thank you so much for being
with us just in terms of that prime
ministerial visit at to the north
earlier this week do you detect detector
a change in tone from this conservative
government when it comes to support for
the partner for the power house I think
it's been a remarkable change so for the
last three years under Teresa Mays
government I think that the progress has
probably been most generally sees
generously described as lackluster I
think the reality of what Boris Johnson
announced last week including the
funding and a commitment to fund the new
line between Leeds and Manchester which
we believe should come through the city
centre here in Bradford the great city
of Bradford to really transform and
unlock the economic potential that
currently isn't being taken advantage of
in the north is a completely new
approach from the government and I think
that particularly by putting Jay berry
round the cabinet table appointing those
like Ritchie sunic who were strong
supporters of northern infrastructure I
think we have also got a team around the
prime minister who can genuinely deliver
which we we didn't have previous to the
change of government but does it go far
enough I hear news this morning that a
hundred business leaders eart from the
north er are writing to the prime
minister with one key suggestion yeah
absolutely so on devolution we've been
writing today along with John heaps
who's the chairman of the auction
Building Society where I'm speaking to
you from but also business leaders like
Juergen Maya who runs Siemens Chris
Oglesby he runs Brentwood's a number of
our chambers of commerce like the chief
executive of the chamber in East
Lancashire these people have all come
together to send a clear message along
with those who run a lot of our our big
organizations supporting business like a
local enterprise partnerships they've
all come together here in the north to
say that devolution is a key step we
need to take because unless we unlock
the northern economy even if we improve
the infrastructure we won't have the
skills and talent our businesses need
and so if you look for instance here in
Bradford we don't have a directly
elected mayor with responsibility for
improving services here in Yorkshire
outside of the Sheffield City region we
don't have that in Cumbria or in
Lancashire or in
over further down in Cheshire in the
northwest we need to fix that problem so
that rather than only half the north
having a directly elected mayor we get
to the hundred percent figure which we
believe alongside that investment
infrastructure would deliver the vision
that George Osborne supported and made
happen when he was Chancellor and that
Jim O'Neill who sort of came up with the
intellectual ideas wanted to to achieve
because although he wanted to bring the
north together as a virtual city using
that new line which Boris mentioned we
need to make sure that those in Bradford
who want the jobs those talented young
people this is Britain's youngest city
have got the skills to take jobs whether
they be here in organisations like this
in financial services or across in
Manchester or across in Leeds the moment
they don't get the support with skills
because we haven't got that power here
in the north to influence the skill
system and they also don't have the
infrastructure we need both of those to
happen and I think under Boris Johnson
whatever people's views about the wider
government's policies we do have someone
who having been an ex-mayor being the
mayor of London previously is committed
to support that agenda it can given the
support that you are seeing from Boris
Johnson for the power house I mean why
is it impossible for these changes to be
made at a remove at a distance from
central government rather than at
through the process of devolution that
you're asking for I think the key point
is that if you want to spend for
instance 39 billion pounds building a
new railway I would accept that the
Treasury and central government might
have some role in that and then I think
the North though could play a much
bigger role along with the private
sector in being trusted to deliver that
project in a different way to how we
traditionally deliver infrastructure but
if you want to for instance improve
skills you can't do that from a desk in
Whitehall and what we've seen around the
adult education budget for instance
which is now being spent by a Tory mayor
in Teesside by Labour mayors in places
like Liverpool and Greater Manchester
they're doing a much better job with the
existing scarce resources so we want to
spend more money in the north but I
think when Richard leaves who is the
leader of Manchester who first pioneered
this agenda still very much part of the
team driving forward the Greater
Manchester economy he was really clear
but as well as getting that new
investment that we need in the north of
England to rebalance our economy it'll
be pretty silly if we didn't spend
better the money we've already got and
when you look for instance at how Andy
Burnham is challenging and improving
transport in Greater Manchester he's
building the B lines
a network of cycle lanes he's not just
doing what maybe somebody in Whitehall
would do and the response that from
communities from businesses is actually
that we think we're getting better
decisions through our directly elected
mayors and unfortunately a moment places
like here in Bradford and missing out
despite the fact that this is one of
those places but if we don't take
advantage of it the UK won't succeed
whatever happens with brexit nevermind
the north of England and this is in the
national interest
so I also believe for instance in other
parts of the country the devolution
could play a bigger role I've also would
be an admirer for instance on G Street
in the West Midlands who's doing a great
job with his economy so the north is
obviously the place where there are 15
million people where the government can
make the biggest difference but I also
think the decentralization of power
moving away from a Whitehall machine
which is fundamentally broken in terms
of making the right investments for our
country is the only way that we're going
to move forward as a country and it's
the only way that we're going to tackle
that underlying productivity gap because
we know that making poor decisions from
Whitehall is one of the reasons why
outside of London the southeast we don't
see the type of economy but we will need
to have if we're going to succeed in the
global race how convinced then or are
you of the merits of hs2 I think we
would be absolutely supportive hs2 and I
think that the northern business leaders
who have written this letter have also
many occasions lobbied for that and I
hope that Claire Fox gets and difficult
questions for me I think the only policy
is a no deal Breck sir and cancelling
hs2 from from the brexit party and as
they want to win votes the north of
England I think their economic
decision-making and rationale is pretty
pretty appalling I think that what we
would say about hs2 is it is more
valuable because it will be linked to
northern powerhouse rail so the the
train line that the Prime Minister back
last week between Leeds and Manchester
that's part of the wider network to get
you from Newcastle to Manchester Airport
from Hull to Liverpool that wider
network when you plug it into HS to will
really rebalance the economy and I think
that that challenge that we want people
to get around the north of England for
jobs we also want to be able to bring in
talent from slightly further afield and
a lot of people for instance to go to
Birmingham if you live in the north of
England in leaves or Bradford it's
almost impossible other than by getting
in a car to get to places like
Birmingham the transport networks to get
around and between our regions are
absolutely appalling and so in this part
of the world where we haven't built a
new railway east-to-west since the
Victorians I think it's perfectly right
that the country built a new line for
instance from Leeds to Birmingham and on
to London a new line from Manchester to
Birmingham and a new line between Leeds
and Manchester because if we do that we
will get those really transformative
economic benefits and I think a concern
for me is that despite the National
Infrastructure Commission saying we can
afford both we can also actually afford
Crossrail to if you do both those
projects within 1 point 2 percent of GDP
there are some people out there saying
we have to choose between be able to get
people for instance young people be able
to get from Bradford to Manchester for
work or people from Leeds and Bradford
being able to get to London or
Birmingham having the capacity we need
on that hs2 network I don't think anyone
in London had to choose between building
the new rail lines Paris the Channel
Tunnel rail link HS 1 to give it its
proper title or building cross rail
which I think when it opens will
demonstrate the real value for money
that it will bring for London taxpayers
who have partly contributed along with
government to make that scheme happen I
believe that in the north of England we
deserve both we deserve the ability to
be able to get people to work reliably
and quickly and we deserve better
connections to the rest of the country
and I think that when the government's
review of hs2 has been concluded I think
if we can get a delivery model that
integrates hs2 and building northern
powerhouse Rail together we'll be able
to save money but we'll also be able to
demonstrate that that combined Network
actually will be more valuable than
doing either hs2 or northern powerhouse
Rail on its own I think by building both
projects will deliver the vision that
George Osborne has which was that
connectivity can really unlock that
growth anyway Henry Morrison at many
thanks for joining us